my diseases were put into complete
remission by an all-meat diet a very
brief background i was diagnosed with
juvenile rheumatoid arthritis when i was
seven 37 affected joints 16 years being
treated with immunosuppressants chronic
fatigue absolutely crippling depression
i lost my hip and my ankle to arthritis
and had them replaced when i was 17. i
tried going the medical route and it
didn't work when i was 23 my skin had
started to break down from rashes and
those stopped healing i couldn't sleep
on my shoulders my right wrist felt like
it was going to be next for my third
joint replacement anyway i decided to
reduce my diet dramatically just to rule
it out not because i thought it had
anything to do with my health i cut it
down to meat and whole foods within two
months it eliminated nearly all of my
symptoms i managed to get off of ssris
and adderall and immune suppressants we
were absolutely shocked two months of
that limited diet put me into remission
after 20 years of an autoimmune disorder
that destroyed my joints